all right it's good
i love it wow suddenly my feet are very
comfortable
[Music]
[Applause]
the end of every project is always
bittersweet
and i can't believe that it's the final
season
this has given bittersweet a whole new
meaning for me
it's wild to think back on the first
conversation i had with elena i always
go back to that because since day one
it's always been it's always been us um
and this unbelievably incredible team
yeah i actually think we have a pretty
unconventionally close relationship for
this type of work because haley came
from the world of movies and i came from
the world of theater and neither of us
necessarily knew the rules and so we
were inventing our own rules
it feels like there's this triangle
which is haley elena emily and it's been
this constant dialogue and interplay
between
all of us and haley's birthday is one
day apart from emily dickinson's which
is a crazy coincidence that we
found out
for me i have ate slept and breathed
nothing but dickinson for clothes on
like seven or eight years now actually
it's hard not to be obsessed with emily
dickinson there's something about this
particular human
that continues to amaze me and surprise
me and fascinate me
[Music]
emily has emerged from her inferno which
is that she confronted all the worst
fears about her family and herself
and now she is taking charge and agency
in a new way when i was having initial
conversations about emily when i first
was having this idea for the show people
didn't know who emily dickinson was or
if they did they only basically knew
that she was reclusive the only thing
emily dickinson did was wear white
and cry but she had a wicked sense of
humor and she made fun of her family and
she made fun of herself and yet she
could also take these existential trips
going places in her mind that are pretty
scary to go
confronting death and confronting
loneliness and confronting the limits of
love i'm pretty confident that at this
point like a young person in high school
is probably learning a pretty different
version of emily and one that is in fact
closer to what the scholars and
historians who have been studying her
all along have said that was awesome
haley resetting
i really can't thank elena enough for
portraying these characters in a very
vibrant way that you can really be like
oh these people were real thinking
breathing living soul feeling people
elena constructed this show around this
crazy blend of her sense of humor and
her historical understanding of emily
dickinson and her commentary on a
contemporary world that kind of wild
combination of things
elena created a really amazing show that
we are all so proud of and to now have
come so full circle with her directing
the finale of our final season is just
not anything i would have ever imagined
i guess as far as just how far we've all
come how much we've all grown together
[Music]
period pieces are my favorite there's
just such a
i mean you get to come to work every day
and immerse yourself in a completely
different world than what you're used to
and that starts
first thing in the morning when you're
going through hair and makeup and you
get
cinched into a corset um this whole
experience has been absolutely
incredible and really unlike anything
i've done before
season one the first thing we ever shot
was a dinner table scene those scenes
always take forever to shoot because you
got to get all the way around the table
close-ups the y's and all of that you're
there all day and as tedious as it was
we built such a strong foundation right
then right there around that table in
our home on the very first day
and then season two we settled into
knowing that we can go with it on the
fly because we've built this foundation
that we're confident in
in season three it's just great to have
gotten to a point where we know that
this end result is gonna be something
that we're proud of we know exactly what
we have to do to make it that and we
might as well just have a good time
getting there
i don't think we've had this much fun in
the three years of the show my brother
wasn't in front and maybe spontaneously
wasn't wrong
oh my god oh my god what is hard to do
with toby is keep a straight face
parents uh i think we're getting
together oh i'm sorry
sorry toby would you back up just a
little bit yeah toby
he always seems to provoke the sparkle
to come out in my eye and i try to get
his to come out as well
oh
my god anna she has given these crazy
absurd things to do you're gonna see my
word but she always makes it
work leave it to anna to look beautiful
while she's covered in mud at the same
time
the other day that's been the job there
was a kind of perfect concoction made up
to drench my hair and my face and we
added little flowers i'm going out after
this it was so much fun to film that day
it was comedy gold
yeah they're both there i think we roll
i think i just saw my mouse laura the
director sent me an email basically
saying i want to get a gauge on your um
level of comfort with mice
and i i truly was like listen i don't i
don't have anything against them but
like i don't think i would voluntarily
hold them right so i get to set and i
very quickly learned that that jane was
um
not okay with it
i kept trying to just convince myself
that it was a showbiz mouse
so maybe you'd be trained and take a
break at craft service or something
it was hard i'm still actually getting a
little bit like
phoclapsic about it
jane and i have really grown close she
just has always made me feel good in
what i'm doing she's always been very
reassuring and um
she's wonderful ladies and gentlemen mrs
dickinson is back
when i'm filming
always
i wear a locket
with a picture of emily dickinson
and it's my little secret
cause george you know loves emily so
he's got a little walk-in and i just
always wear it and nobody knows what i
do
[Music]
are you gonna do something mischievous
he's like that's his mischievous walk
okay i'm just gonna
get the lay of the land and then then
i'll pop out
every moment is a joy with each of the
dickinson family members i'm just here
to scare
emily helped him a plant
what
on the planet
that's nice
adrian is the most fun
uh he's like the perfect big brother
we've all been so integrated into each
other's personal lives as well
[Music]
when i first started working on
dickinson i was 20
and i just moved to new york i had no
idea about
living in america it was a huge culture
change for me and
honor adrian and haley they really have
been my my siblings and i i love that
about our relationship
i remember early on i would always bring
a guitar to set and i was jamming with
anna ella in me and we would just hang
out and play songs to each other
i i had to learn how to do a little bit
of piano and the one thing that i knew
how to do was heart and soul which i'm
sure was driving everyone else in the
room crazy because everyone's heard it a
million times but adrienne of course was
really gung-ho and was like no you do it
and i'll start over here and then we
just
yeah
revived
five down the piano oh clearly the most
musical of the gap
the whole jane gang every time they have
some sort of moment they make the
absolute most of it and it's amazing
i'm spoiled working with this cast
my little crew like jane gang you know
we've been tight since the first season
we've all gotten to a point where we are
so comfortable i mean we are constantly
calling each other out they're inside
jokes we just have such a
such a bond i feel that really can't be
broken at this point it's ella's
birthday so we're gonna run into her
room and we're just gonna go surprise
with balloons and cake and things
i had no idea that anyone knew it was my
birthday and i i came back to my
dressing room too uh haley had filled
the room with balloons
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone was piled into the room yay
happy birthday
there's something about this dickinson
family that is just so hard to compare
to anything else and after a very crazy
unpredictable year and a half that we
all had i just feel so lucky to be to be
here
[Music]
of course i went on very smoothly this
morning but it does kind of hurt in one
spot but i'm gonna just stick it out and
see how long they last oh boy
when is lunch
so that'll be the only comment i make
right so that's it i got it out it's all
over from here okay
we wrote season three in the pandemic
and have made it through to here
going from sort of total lockdown to
suddenly coming into this world where
you're seeing like old friends and
workmates i mean i was just so happy
it was very emotional for me when i
first came back for season three just
being so thankful for every crew member
that would come here and put their mask
on and get so many tests so we can all
be together and make this show all i
want to do is find a way
to keep hope alive
a conversation that i had with elena
very early on about season three in
general being about hope this family's a
joke i felt that in order for that to
feel real emily would have to be knocked
off her feet a couple times dad because
it could come across as much easier said
than done when you haven't experienced
what it's like to be hopeless i'm
seceding from this family
wrestling with hope is certainly the
theme of the season and especially this
one where there was this racial
reckoning in our country
we have always known that the civil war
was looming in emily and her family's
future
but it really became uncanny the way
that the world sort of caught up to the
show
suddenly there's this public
consciousness about the oppression and
marginalization of sex of people and
similarly we're writing about the civil
war and about these black soldiers
finding their autonomy and fighting back
so the parallels right themselves
but remember it's often darkest
right before the dawn
i have experienced first hand
this show has made people feel
seen
you experience meeting people around the
world that have felt like this has made
an impact on their lives and that's all
you could ever want at the end of the
day right action this show has such a
modern flair he was able to put our own
spin on like our own swag on it
i feel like each of these characters is
their own universe and these battalions
in real life the people who fought in
them were filled with those match dreams
and hopes and laughter well as a matter
of fact i am from massachusetts so
remember we thought he was white
no he's not i knew that because i
actually watched this show
[Applause]
that tension between the contemporary
language and story lines and the period
is the sort of joy of dickinson one of
the last few fittings we have a couple
of options to look at
i often get asked where we get the
clothes like what labels do i like to
use and it makes me laugh because there
is no 1860s section at sacs we don't
shop these things we make everything
it takes about 200 hours or more to make
these 200 hours or more to make these
clothes
i was actually blown away by the level
of elegance that our design team was
able to reach
in the inferno episode sue wasn't
originally written
to be in men's attire
and elena had this idea midway through
the season that emily and sue could sort
of be like a bride and groom and that
sue could be in a beautiful tailored
men's suit and that emily would be in
this incredible sort of brighter
frankenstein type dress
thanks you guys are amazing
[Music]
to get to a point where we are making a
show about two women in love i feel
incredibly grateful for the emily's
ensues of history and so we have a
moment of canoodling and then
then we step back
that's the right energy just like that
if you all did exactly that it would
film gorgeously our characters have been
through quite the roller coaster of
emotions together and ella and i have
gotten to a point where the two of us
can look at each other and we just know
exactly how the others feeling
the question is who gets seen and who
doesn't and what are we to make of a
history that has erased minimized
marginalized again and again the
contributions of women people of color
queer people shout it scream it i can't
hear you
yes we are re-staging fox that walt
whitman went to during the 1860s
[Music]
and it was a bohemian and queer car it's
really uh emotional to watch this
recovered history question right
is there another song on a similar
channel yeah they throw on and shock
everyone i had pulled silas aside and i
just said can we just throw in a random
mix of music and just see what happens
and sure enough there was a moment where
all of us break out into
what feels like
we're like suddenly in a music video
this moment of freedom comes over the
whole room and everybody is one and it's
a really beautiful moment
you were in true grit
you were that little kid
i always find it so fascinating when we
have guest stars come on i am new york
and they just truly what's up girl make
the space their own got anywhere to be
nah bro never more i read the role and i
was like okay i couldn't really see
myself doing that so it's just been
really exciting to see it come to life
oh you like it you're hot thank you this
is great this is really good material
i'm gonna go take some notes it's a
really surreal thing when you take what
we know about who this character was
and it's just brought to life in front
of everybody is this part of the
interview it's extraordinary to watch
someone embody a character so fully so
immediately to write poetry you have to
be willing to go all the way down to
hell
okay your energy is so intense and this
is emily dickinson saying that
ah dreams
it's been eight weeks
we started the war hospital we went to
foss we ended up in a family sing-along
i wanted to have a musical episode
because something that really is true
from emily dickinson's life is that she
played the piano
you know at the dickinson homestead was
a large collection of sheet music which
you can still go to the library and see
and emily and her family just like any
19th century family would have frequent
piano sing-along nights and sing like
the popular music of the day and so we
wanted to have an opportunity for each
of our really gifted cast members to
sing
when we were shooting that sing-along
stuff
hayley has a moment where she sings hard
times
it's a beautiful stephen foster song
that was around during the civil war but
could have been written yesterday and we
went from being in these like righteous
joyous moods to all sitting watching
hayley perform that song and i i think
we all wept
i suggested that austin hear it from
outside and come in and sing it with
emily just to sing with haley was
incredible
adrian came up with this beautiful
harmony at the end of
[Music]
hard
it
come again no more
we're beside ourselves over the fact
that we like finally got the chance to
sing together dude
haley is very gifty i love watching her
work it's such a beautiful song i really
admire her
[Music]
it's just been incredible to be a part
of something
from the ground up
that's a pretty good shot right there
and i feel very lucky to be trusted by
so many people to be in this position
that's a privilege actually like that
it's been really inspiring to see haley
stepping into her own as a producer who
isn't afraid to speak her own mind we
can take a second to find this but we
have to land on something specific so
then maybe she just stands and watches
haley knows what it means to be the lead
role in a show that has hundreds of
people involved and how much it all
comes back to like the energy that she's
bringing thank you all hayley's a deeply
empathetic person
and wants us to have a good time
[Music]
i love coming in here on friday getting
everybody hyped up all right all right
all right i know you guys have been
waiting for me
i'm here i made it i came downstairs
with shots
and letting them know how eternally
grateful i am for them showing up here
every single day
that last emily scene of looking out to
the water it's an iconic moment and we
wanted to be there for haley
adrian and ella and i came up to watch
haley shoot the last scene of the show
it's really fun to be on set to support
her and be with each other
under elena's lead she has really set
the tone in terms of just the gravity of
what we're doing
it's been so nice for me to direct this
final episode of season three and to
feel like in some ways it is just the
conversation between me and haley after
we've had you here for a moment we will
cue the dog to run it okay
make sure you get up and already hear
you turn around
that's one thing that's been so amazing
about having you direct this last
episode is to end this show how we
started with a
very clear point of view on who this
character is in season one it was all
about the fact that if emily was a
normal victorian girl she would have
been getting married and instead she
chose to stay committed to her art and
everything that's happened since then
has only been the essential fire of an
artist
on the beach where our show ends it felt
very symbolic she's been through
quite a lot
to bring it all to an end at such a
beautiful place that represents emily's
future
all the poems she hasn't written are out
on the horizon of that water
and it was just so beautiful to be there
myself too and think that this has been
such an incredible journey and emily
finds her place and she finds where
she's headed and she feels really good
about it so that was a kind of a cool
moment for me
i've just been corseted for the last
time on the show baby
whoa and i actually feel so great i've
never felt so good in this corset i know
we both feel so so fortunate for getting
to bring this show out into the world
catch my breath
when you're so in it it becomes sort of
a blur and the moments that i have where
i'm able to sort of step back and look
at what we have accomplished in three
seasons uh is just it makes me emotional
i'm so proud of the work that we've done
it's just the greatest gift to feel like
you're walking away from a show with a
closer relationship to the people you're
around
let's party my platonic friend george is
going off to war and being like will i
ever see my friends again and i'm with
these people i've been with for so long
i'll catch myself actually look around
and be like no i don't want to say
goodbye to any of you
we've been together
every day for four months each
year and it's emotional getting to the
end of this show
i feel like it's not over because we're
not done being a family we're not done
keeping in touch
i just feel like i am able to stand back
and appreciate the work that every
single person has put in here i'm
sitting in this room for the first time
again and the wallpaper i mean i've
looked at this wallpaper for a while now
and i i can't tell you how much i
seem to appreciate it in this moment
what an incredible group of people we
got to call a family on this show
bye y'all
i loved it
you